they came and tried to stop you you
became the target which is weird as a
journalist I would think it's weird to
be targeted like this well I mean I'd
had experience doing hard-hitting
stories where the subject of this story
had pushed back but nothing like what I
encountered in the Thera nose saga so
the initial response once I started
confronting the company with my
reporting several months into my
reporting I gained a critical mass of
information and I went to ther notes and
at first they put me off they hired an
external PR guide to just sort of give
me the runaround and after about two
months of that I I told them you know
this strategy is not going to work I'm
not gonna go away meanwhile Elizabeth
Holmes was making the rounds of tech
conferences health care conferences
giving an interview to just about every
other journalist in America on the cover
of like 20 publication rates she was on
Charlie Rose one evening which is when I
really lost my patience yeah and the
next day I said to this issue return to
you you're a call but she's on Charlie
Rose right and every other event right
right not a red flag at all at this
point I'd been asking to meet with her
and and you know putting to them
questions that I had for two months and
so from there from that point on when it
became clear to them that I would not go
away the strategy shifted from ignoring
him to waging a an aggressive
counter-attack and and the first step in
that counter-attack was to send David
Boies and several of his law firm
associates as well as Heather king of
former Hillary Clinton aide who had been
a partner at Boys schiller Flexner and
who was now fairness as general counsel
to our offices at the journal in midtown
Manhattan rice for a sit yeah and I and
I figured you know there were gonna be
fireworks so I came with my editor Mike
sicken olfi and and J Conti he was our
lawyer who advised the newsroom on
sensitive journalistic matters and we
kind of have had a showdown for five
hours in this conference room five hours
right what happens you walk in and what
if there's a Eagles or their bagels and
yogurt what is that what's a setup the
first thing they do is they put little
tape recorders two of them at each end
of the conference room table
intimidation tactic press record and
it's very clear with that doing that
that that they are taking that they're
considering that this meeting is a
deposition in a future legal proceeding
right I mean it was a shot across the
bow yeah that's an intimidation tactic
and the - that's the move so - out these
tape ones are these digital so that they
can make sure to capture everything
every digital they take I think they
were digital they didn't and so then I
pull out my iPhone and I press record as
if you have it yeah and here we go and
then they get you know very aggressive
and their demeanor their their stance it
quickly becomes clear is that I through
my reporting have miss appropriated
their nose trade secrets and I need to
destroy them or return them immediately
I have these I have a list of 80
questions that I had sent them two weeks
prior that they'd had plenty of time to
prepare for is it about try to start
going through them and you know at the
heart of these questions is uh you know
how many of the blood tests on the menu
how many of the 250 tests are done with
actual their nose technology and how
many are done with commercial machines
that you've hacked yeah and the answer
is we can't talk about that it's a trade
secret and we sort of go around in
circles over this question and and David
Boies gets angry and threatening and his
tone and notice he say like don't you
know who I am I could bury you guys I he
tells us that he tells us at one point
that he's gonna send us a letter after
the meeting that's gonna make clear
their noses legal stance which we did
get three days later and you the end the
letter and and other letters you know
pretty much threaten to sue us if we
didn't hand in our reporting but he also
said that the only way that we were
gonna get responses to our questions was
if we signed NDA's because the Thera
knows proprietary technology these trade
secrets were so valuable that quest and
LabCorp the two dominant players in the
lab industry
trying to find out answers to these
questions by any means possible it's
interesting you mention that because
when that came up and I heard that that
was part of the excuse that they were
that this was some grand conspiracy I
just to myself well that's hogwash to me
like supposedly queston lab court were
conducting industrial espionage to try
to find out the answers to these very
questions that I thought surprise
winning team member of The Wall Street
Journal seems like a great route to go
ya know that became the line later that
I was in league with quest and LabCorp
at that at the point of that meaning it
wasn't so much there I was in league
with them it was that you know we need
to sign NDA's because that that the
information is so valuable did you ever
find out if David Boies actually knew
how absolutely insane the actual state
of the company was at that time or do
you think he just went out there and
blindly defended her I think it's more
of the latter I I don't think he
realized right the shenanigans that were
going on in the lab I don't think he
realized that fewer than 12 of the tests
were being done with there and it was in
a way a victim is a well-paid one right
I mean his the the behavior of his law
firm is you know and we can get into
that yeah after that five-hour meeting
there were more twists and turns and I I
find the their behavior reprehensible
really and beyond the pale but as any as
far as technology they would use any
means necessary to try to get the story
killed there that kind of law firm
within days of that five-hour meeting
you know I came to the conclusion that
one of my sources a young woman by the
name of Erika Chung who's a character in
the book was being surveilled because a
man shows up in an SUV late one night at
the parking lot of her new employer in
Sunnyvale California and she comes out
and the man walks out of the SUV makes a
beeline toward her with an envelope
inside the envelope is a letter from
David Boies telling her she must meet
with him and his associates by a certain
day at a certain time otherwise she's
gonna be sued and the address on the
envelope is the address of a friend of
her a colleague of hers and friend who
lives in East Palo
and erica has been staying at this
colleagues place for less than two weeks
at that point Wow no one other than the
colleague even knows that this is where
Erica is living Wow not even her mother
so there severely there is no other way
to know that she's living there than to
have followed her and so she calls me
and at that point it's kind of a funny
moment because I'm in my car in Brooklyn
I live in Brooklyn and you're a Brooklyn
I do right yeah yeah you have to move
your your car for parking and so I I'm
sitting in my car double-parked and and
in my neighborhood in Brooklyn waiting
for the street cleaner to go by
listening to the radio and my phone
rings I answered turn the radio down and
it's Erica and she is petrified of
course she has spent the weekend at her
friend's house not gone outside with the
blinds you know closed she doesn't know
what to do
she's become convinced that she's being
followed she explains to me the the
incident in the parking lot the previous
Friday we're now Monday morning and I
agree with her that you know there's
only one possible conclusion which is
that they've had private investigators
following her but I tell her I'm pretty
sure this is only recent that the
surveillance only recent and that they
don't have proof that you're a
confidential source of mine and so I
managed to convince her not to go to the
meeting with the Boise Schiller
attorneys and to just go about her
business she no longer works for Thera
knows she has no obligation to even
acknowledge any attempts to make contact
with her and I tell her just go about
your business
yeah but then the this scorched earth
campaign of intimidation of my source
picks up hmm and one of the other
sources that I had gotten in contact
with to corroborate what my first source
had told me was a young man by the name
of Tyler Schultz whose grandfather is
George Schultz the the famous former
secretary of state under Reagan who
essentially you know won the Cold War is
as famous and individual in American
politics as exists right and even now in
his 90s remains revered and in
Republican circles and this is his
grandson or nephew this is his grandson
and
what many people may not know about
George Shultz's he lives right off the
Stanford campus and Palo Alto is
passionate about science has always been
passionate about science
Elizabeth had met him in early 2011
through someone at Stanford Medical
School and she had wowed him with the
claims of what her technology could do
and he had shortly thereafter joined her
board and then introduced her to all his
buddies at the Hoover Institution the
the think-tank on that Stanford campus
and so that's how she came to meet Henry
Henry Kissinger and Bill Frist Sam Nunn
bill Perry who was secretary of defense
under Clinton and and before long had
the Sterling Board Tyler had been
introduced to Elizabeth at his
grandfather's house and had gone to work
there for summer as an intern and then
upon graduating the next year in the
fall of 2013 had gone to work there full
time and had spent eight months at the
company and become convinced that the
company was built on a series of lies
and was essentially a fraud and had
tried to alert his grandfather George to
this to protect him to protect him and
also because he was concerned about
unreliable test results people's lives
people okay and had been unable to
convince his grant his grandfather that
he was telling the truth even though he
had brought on his last day or the day
he had quit that evening he had brought
Erica who had been a friend of his that
he had met at fairness with him to
George's house say to people explain
right so it wasn't just Tyler and the
point was look I have a colleague to
corroborate what I'm telling you and and
George had refused to believe them and
continued to believe Elizabeth and so
Tyler and and Erica had both left the
company and and had had to pretty much
you know keep it bottled up and I had
made contact with both of them they had
become my sources and so I went in May
of 2015 I went and met with both of them
I met Erica one night and the next day I
met with Tyler and Mountain View and
then suddenly you know a month later
Tyler goes dark I can't reach him
anymore
oh they got him and I figured they're
putting the screws to him yeah you know
he had been calling me from a burner
phone because he was paranoid that the
company would would figure out he was
talking to me and and he was using this
made-up name for an email address and
that's how also how we were
communicating and that's how he had sent
me emails and other documents he'd kept
from his stint at their nose and
suddenly he went dark I had even called
his mom reached her left a message no
word back and so I figured you know they
were they were putting the screws to him
to it I didn't learn what was actually
going on with Tyler until much later a
year later when I was able to resume
contact with him and I learned that in
late May of 2015 so a couple weeks
before that five-hour showdown with boys
at our offices they ambushed him at his
grandfather's house boys Schiller
attorneys ambushed him and you know this
one attorney in particular Mike Brill
was like an attack dog and and insisted
that he knew that Tyler had talked to a
Wall Street Journal reporter and that he
needed to admit it and that he needed to
sign these documents and named the
journals other sources eventually George
came to Tyler's defense assured these
lawyers out they came back the next
morning on Elizabeth Holmes's orders
that gave rise to another surreal scene
Tyler decided he needed his own legal
representation
ended up lawyering up and then withstood
an intense pressure campaign intensely
you know threats of litigation for
months and amazingly never signed
anything never signed any document the
company put to him his parents had to
spend close to a half-million dollars on
his legal fees crazy and and and he
never caved and and in large part thanks
to that and thanks to his integrity and
his courage I was able to go to press in
October of 2015 with my story right
I let her later revealed
Tyler's role in a front-page story in
Wall Street Journal remember reading it
yeah in in late 2016 and a much more
detailed account of his ordeal is in the
book but this this gives you an idea of
the lengths to wit to which Elizabeth
Holmes and thier nose went to try to
suppress my reporting